SPEAKER: Last time, you saw
how Cloud operations can
help you quickly isolate or
eliminate infrastructure issues
from a limited set of data.
You also saw how
to quickly filter
alerts to determine whether
your service is being impacted
by an infrastructure issue.
But how can you identify
problems with your service
itself?
And when there's
a problem, how can
you quickly triage
and mitigate it?
Today, I'm going to show you
how to manage services running
on GKE with Cloud Operations.
Welcome to "Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Does this look familiar?
It's really hard to determine
if your service is actually
healthy from infrastructure
signals like these.
In chapter 6 of the
SRE book, we say
that your monitoring system
should address two questions--
what's broken and why.
Signals from your
infrastructure may tell you
why something is
happening, but they
don't tell you anything about
the reliability of your service
itself as experienced by users.
To understand that, you need
good Service Level Indicators
or SLIs that measure service
reliability and Service Level
Objectives or SLOs that set
specific reliability targets.
We looked at how to configure
an SLO for a service running
on GKE by using load balancer
metrics back in episode two.
We'll link to it if you didn't
get a chance to watch it.
So what happens when
there's a problem?
Let's have a look at
how Cloud operations can
help you figure out what to do.
Let's start on the
services overview page.
We can see that we have a
service with an SLO alert
firing.
In this case, our service
is running on GKE.
Let's have a look
at the GKE Dashboard
to see what's going on.
Here, we can see that
we have an unhealthy SLO
for this Kubernetes service.
Let's have a closer look.
Here's our SLO and
the alert letting
us know we're burning
error budget right now.
We can also confirm that our
SLI is severely degraded.
What could be happening?
In the Metrics tab, we
can see that the pod
name was recently changed.
And this seems to correspond
to when the alert fired,
so something has changed.
Let's try to figure out what.
Let's go to the GKE Workload
screen and look at the workload
that we're running.
When we look at the revision
history for workload,
we can see that a new revision
was rolled out a few minutes
before the alert fired.
This may be our culprit.
Let's roll this
release back and see
if that restores our service
back to a healthy state.
Now that we rolled
back that release,
let's check the state
of our workload.
Under Revision History, we can
confirm that we've rolled back
to a known good version.
Let's go to Services and
confirm that the error budget
burn alert is no longer firing.
When we check the
status of our service,
we can see that the SLO is
no longer firing an alert.
And our SLI has also recovered.
So, we were able to
identify a problem
with our service running
on GKE, determined
that it was caused
by bad rollout,
and rolled back to
a known good state
to recover the health
of our service.
Thanks for joining me today.
We saw how Cloud Operations
can help you quickly triage
and mitigate application issues
for services running on GKE.
I hope this helps you keep
your applications reliable
and keep your users happy.
Thanks so much for watching.
Don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out
on more "Engineering for
Reliability with a Google
Cloud."
See you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]